[Music]
hello you're in great danger get out of
there now open safe house 6 welcome in
the Townsend agency
I run a covert group with exceptional
women so you guys are like lady spies we
work outside the rules in secret
together you may not know we exist but
we are always watching you are in the
presence of angels so you want to train
you be an angel hell yeah
give me my wings
[Music]
sit down keep your hands where I can see
them really not supposed to be touching
things in here unless you're supposed to
be touching things I mean you're
adorable J is that you flirting with a
handsome
[Music]
the best part is them taking down
international criminals with you guys
and the day-drinking that's what I like
the most
[Music]
so I can just take whatever I want Baro
is that an actual rule
[Music]
ain't no time to go to work
[Music]
Bosley angels oh this looks very
promising outstanding but what about
Australian Johnny
oh you're gonna regret this yeah that's
gonna give you the twelve because you
just talk way too much you're super
clinging you've come on way too strong
you are the most incredible woman that
I've ever met I know so that's four
months surveillance two countries and
the most embarrassing date I have ever
been on in my life are we good I will
address this to the US Justice
Department along with all your new
friends here we're good to go see you
didn't see this guy he was a pro and he
brought quite a lot of firepower for
such an easy target yeah he was so extra
right I could take that girl out with
like a fly swatter and he walks up in
this urban assault vehicle so we're
thinking what he was maybe she was being
watched but what if we are and by who
hey I'm kind of getting this you know
you guys are like lady spies and I just
need you to explain who this guy is and
why was he shooting at you oh you he was
shooting at you and me the shooters are
ghosts your file says that you are a
systems engineer on the Callisto project
you know about Callisto we know about a
lot of things that you graduated top of
your class at MIT that you take Krav
Maga on Sundays you ride your bike to
work you think yellow is one of your
colors when in fact it's no one's that
you could be dating a lot more if you
played up those cheekbones and your
online profile pictures what we don't
know is why someone once you did
[Music]
the closet of my dreams and I just get
to take whatever I want
Laura is that an actual rule okay so you
want to start with a protective base
layer I recommend the Peter tummy sole
yeah some kind of polymer material
bulletproof composite for teamö it was
originally developed as a protective
layer for spacecraft
yeah and it's a brother doesn't dig
progress how we doing down here
ah we're still in the first closet
there's another closet armory open
I felt like it was a great time to
reinvigorate Charlie's Angels who always
been about a sisterhood I also think
it's really fun to fight bad guys with
your friends just a decreased risk she
sees me she made me feel so able like
the exact reason she's making this movie
the way that we as women can only build
each other up because we know each other
through and through Liz wanted these
women to feel authentic because together
we are better I did this movie because
the Liz was spotted project Elizabeth
Banks is a powerhouse she wrote produced
directed and starred in the movie and
that's never happened before in the
trolleys Angels franchise my name is
possibly I'm gonna kick your ass whisp
this world and just expanded it we're
louder we are stronger in numbers the
best part is in picking down
international criminals it's this it's
the you guys taking down criminals is
also fun being women being the heroes on
screen it's important
[Applause]
I wanted to make something that felt
important to limited girls the
celebration of what women can accomplish
when they work together take her to the
closet
get her up I just get to take whatever I
want
Laura is that an actual room ahh fill in
the first box there's another closet
together little colony angel
[Music]